[Applaudissements]
l'eau
paris
[Applaudissements]
ah ah ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non là dedans badou troisième gardien
mon cul
alors qu'est ce qu'on a à une droite en
pleine gueule drastique jakin classique
michel attendez vous avez vraiment
jackie et michel
non en fait on s'appelle tous les deux
prospère et du coup max et donné ses
deux prénoms pour distinguer vas-y
essaye quoi vous appelez prospère essaye
on se perd
voilà pour rien c'est comme ça tu veux
la toucher mais ilan pappe est mort ce
matin elle va pas tu sais non plus à mon
sens où c'est toi tais toi t'es con toi
t'es qui toi tu es qu'on arrête tu en
veux voilà rivage
[Musique]
l'oeil du tigre aux abords commence à
pousser tuchan l'enfant qui devient
homme là il a repéré sa propre envie de
nous tapie qui chatouille je peux pas
tricher tous trois que sa maman d'un
stage la bouche pas bon il pas se perdre
en chemin pour toi que celle du specta
superbe déjà non j'espère mais là encore
en poudre ou d'aller fumer comme ça mais
ça fout ça va pas la tête vous aime
d'amour quoi on est où là
[Rires]
non non [ __ ] reverb ségara ici quoi
bon jeu michel va passer un coup de
balai faut que je m'occupe du team
ils nettoient réparent
bah oui c'est alors tout maintenant
voilà le remède
mangez ceci est mon corps
e
[Applaudissements]
et buzet
ceci est mon sang noir
on resta longtemps n oubliez pas surtout
aimez-vous nsa dans l'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bernon ouais ouais
jusque là j'ai pas dit il a bu une bière
c'est ça votre gibier la gourgandine
décérébrés qui re mêlant copain m'a
battu voilà six ans de pouvoir a pas pu
venir
c'est pour saper simone ont séparé pour
votre chien doit reconnaître que celle
là bas là la fille élevée cheveux noirs
si elle veut les chinois ne dormirai pas
dans la baignoire
face aux colts à l'appel de jésus elle
6e tribaux ou quoi
une péripatéticienne des buts pour une
[ __ ] pas sujet guillaume tu sais qu'il a
fondé l'école péripatéticienne non
aristote et je crois que je peux dire
salon du meuble mazouzi jours
[Applaudissements]
bon je prends des coups ça c'est sûr
mais votre cerveau
je crois que je raconte ce rattrapage
sera pas allez bon courage
allez hop hop hop
à chacun son tour légalement en fait on
a un c'est bien ça c'est important le
soutien ouais il va en avoir besoin
votre pote un bon c'est quoi ton nom
déjà d'un moulin bon ça va tu as que 42
points à rattraper rien d'insurmontable
savoir taille 8 points 8 de moyenne
en plus c'est bien ça symétrique et tout
ça voilà c'est ça c'est symétrique avec
bien sûr tu as eu cinq en anglais 4 ans
shiloh 4 ans shiloh 5 ans c'était quoi
le sujet 1 to sur le choix est
maintenant tu vas aller serrer pour ton
pote moi c'est un truc sur le choix d'un
libertin d'accord et ce huit ans
d'histoire c'est quoi un an glissant
c'est ce départ un film falloir
s'habituer mais bon tu vas prendre philo
est anglais je voulais plutôt prend des
coups
les cours c'est vrai que tu as eu que
neuf sont des cours à temps je
t'explique pourquoi philo c'est mieux
est ce que tu penses que c'est en philo
c'est dans ses cordes
quand même je crois voilà donc ce site à
7 tu peux avoir 8 ans est d'accord sita
8 tu peux avoir neuf je crois ouais et
site à neuf il ya quel raison que t'as
pas 10 je ne sais pas non il n'a pas de
nom et citadis qu'est ce qui empêche
côté 11
voilà ce que c'est que ce n'est pas
idiot votre humeur skype avant et ben
ouais il peut avoir 20 ouais c'est
exactement ce que je voulais entendre
parce que guillaume il va se retirer
doigts du cul et il va bosser tout le
week-end
un guillaume d'accord ok bon on y croit
les gars là on est à fond en avant très
bien sa convocation
[Musique]
chez les élèves bravo à ceux qui ont bac
ça veut dire quoi à lui au second groupe
ça veut dire sur un patient de cabinet
anne au festival on va faire comment
nous pour la bagnole vous êtes dimbokro
avoue que je vais devenir légaux alors
premier arrivé premier servi
[Musique]
l'esa yumi va se retirer vos du cul et
il va bosser tout le week-end d'accord
on reste pas longtemps
[Musique]
est ce que le problème n'est pas que
socrate imagine que le dehors et le lieu
de la vérité non celui de la réalité je
ne sais pas mais en même temps ce cra tu
ne nies team pas que la seule chose que
je sais c'est que je ne sais rien dans
votre cas j'avais cru comprendre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
- f
ouest
socrates même pas qu à la seule chose
que je sais c'est que je ne sais rien on
y croit les cas la mairie
[Applaudissements]
voir la vidéo une formule 1 nous leur
douleur excuse moi euh ya tous les noix
non à la bourse
bon ça veut dire quoi admis au second
groupe
ça va venir tu vas passer un week-end en
herbe
[Musique]
seize élèves bravo à ceux qui ont le bac
je les mecs
bonsoir c'est bien ça nous fait six
morts ça veut dire quoi admis au second
groupe
ça veut dire tu vas passer un week-end
de merde désolé pour ceux qui sont au
rattrapage
et hop hop hop à chacun son tour légal
il va en avoir besoin votre pote on va
faire comment donc pour la bagnole vous
êtes d'un bouquin vous crie que je vais
venir avec vous j'ai dit ah ça c'est une
vraie douceur pourquoi cette année on y
va premier arrivé premier servi
pij
j'ai lu et vous les uns dans les restes
a longtemps
yum il va se retirer baudu qu il va
bosser tout le week-end d'accord ok tu
sors l'enfant qui devient homme la tma
[Applaudissements]
bon on y croit les gars là non
la font prendre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attends tu es sûr que tu cplt ça toi
socrates ne dis pas que la seule chose
que je sais c'est que je ne sais rien
dans votre cas j'avais cru comprendre
quinze élèves bravo à ceux qui ont le
bac ça veut dire quoi a nui au second
rang ça veut dire sur un passé avec un
numéro spécial
on va faire comment donc pour la bagnole
vous avez d'un bouquin vous que je vais
devenir légaux alors qu'on est arrivés
on est servi l'esa iommi va se retirer
vos du q games à bosser tout le week-end
datacore
on resta longtemps
[Musique]